what's the sentence that you use to
define yourself practical optimism
there's a major elimination of fear for
me which is like everything's solvable
if you have a simple life
if you've got simple needs never die in
your own Supply I think too many people
that are optimistic or delusional the
reason so many entrepreneurs lose is
they are artists not operators they're
like I'm gonna make this peanut butter
and jelly sandwich that nobody else has
ever made and I'm going to sell a
million of them without thinking about
bread costs you know without thinking
about location marketing how to hire HR
like people are incredibly not practical
not operational and so mine's not even a
sentence it's two words together that
paint a very clear picture of what's
worked for me as a human being let alone
as a businessman well it's a really fun
podcast for me because it's a little bit
of a role reversal usually Jason is on
the other side of interviewing me uh
Jason is a force in the business content
world and he has a new book uh when I
saw that I said look you know as veteran
chief of Entrepreneur magazine I think
it'd be a good use for my podcast to to
see what you wrote about it why and kind
of shoot the [ __ ] on the current state
of Entrepreneurship I got very fortunate
so did all of you listeners that I think
between that which feels like a year ago
and now the you know potential recession
or maybe we're in it a lot of things are
changing in marketing the world's
changing rapidly so no better time to uh
welcome my friend Jason to the show uh
Jace how are you hey man great to see
you this is really fun to be on the
other side of this I I don't even know
how it's going to go I can't wait why
don't you tell everybody the name of
your book and uh and what it's about and
then we'll get into it sure so the book
is called build for tomorrow and it is a
guide to adaptability the the thinking
here is that everyone is going through
massive change we as a society are going
through big changes anyone in business
is going through big change people's
careers are changing their lives are
changing so how can we
see opportunity of that how can we
navigate it in a way in which we don't
just always see loss which is I think
what people tend to see when they when
they experience change but instead find
gain and this comes out of me having
access to the world's greatest
entrepreneurs I mean you know Gary you
and I have spoken so many times and no
matter what we're talking about this is
really the core of it is adaptability is
is having a mindset in which new things
are growth opportunities rather than
simply a scary replacement for what came
before and I wanted to know how people
are doing that how they are finding ways
to grow despite uncertainty because I
know that that's not something people
are born with it's a skill that you can
learn and I wanted to teach it to others
you know that's an interesting question
you know so much of it's predicated on
fear yeah
how do you feel people can be taught out
of fear insecurity the Judgment of
others this is subject matter that's
always been interesting to me half glass
full yes versus no DNA and versus or DNA
yeah maybe versus no DNA what um what
what out of all these years you know
obviously people are going to read the
book one thing I'm proud of is the
Vayner nation that listens to this
podcast shows up on the books it makes
me happy because I have reading issues
so I I don't crush books but so many of
this audience does and gets so much
value out of it that's why I keep
writing them
um so I know a lot of people can get
value out of it but for the people that
are just going to be able to catch this
Insight from the podcast if you had to
synthesize it what stands out the most
all right so
let me tell you a quick story please
I
I when I started my career I started my
career as a newspaper reporter small
town newspaper reporter like news
Gardner Massachusetts 6 000 circulation
in the 2002 I don't know what it is now
and uh and I I I gotta tell you I loved
being a newspaper reporter because I had
aspired to it but and so people come up
to me at a party and they said what do
you do I have a newspaper reporter I
loved it but a couple years in I
realized man this is a tough industry
it's not really for me I don't like the
hours I don't really like the work I I
feel like I can do something different
here but you know why I stayed in that
job too long it was because I identified
as a newspaper reporter and if I was a
newspaper reporter and I didn't have a
newspaper job then what am I and this is
something we all do where we we identify
with the output of our work with the
thing that we're doing which is fine
makes sense but the problem is that it
leaves us subject to feeling completely
destabilized whenever change happens I
made the same mistake when I got into
magazines I'm a magazine editor and
every time I ran into a big speed bump
in this this issue in this industry and
I've run into many I would be afraid
because I feel like well if I lost being
a magazine editor then I'm nothing
entrepreneurs boy they talk differently
with they often I I was having a
conversation with this guy Greg he's the
CEO of food stirs which is a baking
Mexico you know Baking Company and uh
and we were talking about a major change
that the company was going through it
was it was unpredictable it was a little
scary I asked him if he was freaked out
and he said no because here's what he
said our mission is to bring joy to
people through upgraded sweep baked
goods he just casually tossed that off
but I realized you know what that's what
we all need we need a mission statement
in which every word is not subject to
easy change in which every word is core
to us so that no matter what change is
we have something that does not change
we identify the thing about us that is
always forward-facing that is always
value oriented despite whatever happens
around us so I came up with this phrase
for myself I actually Gary if you've I'd
love to know what you think is like the
kind of Core Essence of you but I'll
tell you what I came up with myself is I
tell stories in my own voice I tell
stories not magazine stories not
newspaper stories not podcasts not books
in my own voice now I'm setting the
terms for how I work and I find that
having that orientation means that Gary
if you and I uh if we're done talking
today and I check my email and
entrepreneur has fired me yep I don't
lose the ability to tell stories of my
own voice that's right what is you you
do a million things what what is what's
the sentence that you use to define
yourself practical optimism
um
because there's always a need for that
yeah I mean I I just I think I'm an
operator you know I'm very aware of
garyvee and all that and aware of why I
do it I actually think it's an
exercising operations creating brand and
awareness leads to opportunity but the
but I also think that I'm deeply
optimistic I'm stunned by it was kind of
how I started this right which is like
there's a major elimination of fear for
me which is like everything's solvable
if you have a simple life if you've got
simple needs never die in your own
Supply you know just you know you know
I'm not fancy I'm from the dirt I like
it in the dirt and then back to
practical I think too many people that
are optimistic or delusional they go
into they go into the reason so many
entrepreneurs lose is they are artists
not operators right they just they're
like I'm gonna make this peanut butter
and jelly sandwich that nobody else has
ever made and I'm gonna sell a million
of them without thinking about bread
costs you know without thinking about
location marketing how to hire HR like
people are incredibly not practical not
operational and so mine's not even a
sentence it's two words together that
paint a very clear picture of what's
worked for me as a human being let alone
as a businessman and an entrepreneur and
you know what's really interesting about
that is that now that I now that I know
that I can I can think about how that
protects you against both ups and downs
right the Ops being that you buy in too
much on anyone up and the down feeling
like you've lost too much because we've
tried we've talked about things that
you've tried that you've invested in
that didn't work out and you just treat
it like a piece of data right you're
just like I just yeah I don't I don't
want to but I you know this may be why I
love sports like
in a in life of sports you it's
impossible to not lose it's almost
impossible not to lose within Seasons
there are really in the 72 dolphins in a
football season that doesn't have that
many games like it's just not reality
and you know I think with
entrepreneurship if you don't have the
stomach for Judgment of others it's
almost impossible to be in the game in a
meaningful way because entrepreneurship
is around risk and too many people are
scared of that thus they cast judgment
on those who are doing it sometimes over
accolades oftentimes envy and jealousy
leading to under accolades and so I'm
just very realistic about it let's go
back to your book what uh the book
process what was the coolest because
there's a lot of aspiring authors on
this
um on this other side of this audio and
video if I asked you what the coolest
moment was so far of having a book just
like Fanboy 16 year old Jason like what
like what like an email from somebody an
English teacher a famous person posting
it that you think is famous or cool like
for me that would be a Jets offensive
lineman versus somebody in Hollywood
like like what's the coolest thing so
far yeah okay yeah I love that I love
that question um so I've had really cool
moments uh the book was up on the NASDAQ
billboard that was awesome Michelle
Pfeiffer just yesterday uh posted a
photo of herself with the book that was
awesome awesome yeah but um but I gotta
tell you the coolest moment like
straight up was I was in the airport
last week uh flying to a to a speaking
event and I I swung into the bookstore
and I saw my book for the first time out
in the wild I took I took a selfie with
it yeah of course and then somebody like
a customer was like is that your book
and so I was like yeah it is and I
started to tell her about it and she
bought it like she bought it and I
signed it for her for a random stranger
and I and I realized like I I am I am
feeling exhausted by the by the like the
business of this book right like just
the the dealing with the dealing with
everything that is involved in selling
it at Mass scale I love the individual
like one-on-one I could go out and sell
a book
by hand two individuals all day I mean I
just I just did it yesterday I walked
into another bookstore the same exact
thing happened took a selfie with
somebody came up asked me about it I
sold them a book I I can't get enough of
that
I love that makes a ton of sense what um
what was the most surprising thing for
you as you went to level two level three
level four of your understanding of
Entrepreneurship
what is the what surprised you
personally the most and then
with Entrepreneur magazine and and just
your your craft and your skill set and
this what do you think most people still
miss
about entrepreneurs in a world where 10
years ago they were the coolest they got
cool yeah yeah 25 years ago it wasn't a
conversation 10 years ago they got cool
and now it's kind of almost like such a
normal part of life yeah some of the
cool is worn off it just kind of
normalized like what do you think the
masses are still missing comma what
surprised you the most when you started
to get your degree in really knowing
entrepreneurs oh man all right so the
thing that surprised me the most
was that I had a I had a uh
a mode of thinking that was limiting my
abilities to grow so so check this out
so I I had this is this builds for
tomorrow is my first book by myself but
back in 2018 i i co-wrote a romantic
comedy like so off of like my but I
recovered a romantic comedy with my wife
and it came out on St Martin's press and
anyway so it came out and I got these
two totally different reactions to it
from my writer friends they all said
that's awesome congratulations from my
entrepreneurs they all said oh that's
interesting what are you going to do
with it because to them the only reason
to have written a romantic comedy was
because I was going to build something
on top of it I was gonna it's gonna
start teaching courses right and and I
realized that entrepreneurs and almost
everybody else have a different way of
thinking everybody else including the
world that I came from has what I like
to Now call horizontal thinking which is
to say you do something you put it out
in the world you move along you do
something else you put it out and you're
building horizontally entrepreneurs
think vertically they only do something
because it is the foundation upon which
the next thing will be built which isn't
to say that it's going to be perfect or
it's going to be straightforward but
they're always thinking about how every
effort is driving future effort that is
not a natural way of thinking but once
you start absorbing that it completely
changes the decisions that you make and
the way in which you conduct yourself
and so now now I filter myself through
is this building is this building
towards something bigger and I'm
constantly revising my idea of what that
is I think we all make a mistake if we
say I've got one place that I'm moving
towards and I gotta make decisions that
only move me there but I do think that
we should have a plan and then a plan to
abandon the plan right so you need
somewhere to go you need momentum you
need to feel like you're moving towards
something but these other ideas these
other opportunities are going to come
along and you need to remain open to
them it's Malcolm Gladwell once told me
self-conceptions are powerfully limiting
and I I just couldn't agree with that
more if you define yourself too narrowly
you will turn down a hundred thousand
all these amazing opportunities right so
so I wanna I wanna have an idea of what
I'm building but I also want to program
into myself the freedom to abandon that
idea and replace it with another idea
but I always want to be building so
that's what surprised me the most the
difference between horizontal thinking
and vertical thinking
um and then the thing that I think
people misunderstand is that
um if you're on the outside and you
watch an entrepreneur and they are out
there and they're they're selling
they're building they're really focused
on something
I think you know I think a lot of people
they they can appreciate that but in a
way they also find it a little dirty
they I think a lot of people see sales
as dirty you know I I was just on an
Instagram live last week and I was
talking about my book and uh and there
was one guy in the comments who was like
don't forget he's getting paid to do
this and I stopped and I was like dude
okay first of all I'm actually not
getting paid per book because if you
know how books work you gotta like yeah
sell them out in the books before you
make any additional money off I mean I
got in advance but then so um but but
here's the number here's the thing
here's the thing that I think people
misunderstand
just because you're selling something
doesn't mean that it's bad in fact I
actually I actually think it's the
reverse what's that I I believe the
reason my career has gone well is
and that I'm a good salesman and
marketer is I only sell stuff I believe
in there you go when I was selling
empathy wines I just knew it was a
better 20 wine right when I'm
vaynermedia is a better agency than
anybody else could hire for I really
believe that in my soul and it's not
delusional because the results have
spoken to it and that's and that's the
thing that I said on that thing because
I said look if you believe that you have
created something of Great Value and
it's a value to other people then it is
your responsibility to make sure they
know about it and have access to it and
use it it's really funny a friend I I
saw so there was a really funny
conversation I have with a group of
friends where that exact theme came up
and said yeah Gary you're selling that
and I said brother you're asking to get
paid to work a job yeah like why don't
you do it for free I don't understand
like like there's this very like funny
conversation amongst entrepreneurs and
non-entreneurs I also think that
entrepreneurs have done a very poor job
in not communicating that
people that are not entrepreneurs are
equally as lucky to entrepreneurs
because if they have found something
that works for them like I'll be honest
with you uh there are many days when I'm
like man
it would have been really cool if the
luck of the DNA draw made me be
passionate about being a number four in
a company because the Delta even between
being a number one and a number two is
just the sheer amount of responsibility
if everybody's listening if you're not
an entrepreneur
but you have kids remember what it was
like to be the kid and judge everything
your parents did and not think about
anything and now know what it feels like
to be the parent like it's just a
totally different world when it's on you
yeah that's right and
what people say about entrepreneurship
is if you could do anything else then go
do it like you have to right yeah which
which frankly is the same thing people
say in media the world that I have come
from if you could do anything else then
go do it because it's easier but when
you take a path that's challenging but
it is also immensely satisfying then
those challenges become
part of the part of the validation right
like they're they're part of the reason
why you're you're doing it and and I
think what you need most is you need to
orient yourself towards
that you are going to be able to deliver
value to people no matter how right no
matter how
um and and and when you're able to think
that way and this goes back to what I
was talking about before it is
separating that like what you do and why
you do it
when you are oriented towards I can
deliver value I can grow I can build
it's going to be difficult but it is
going to be the most satisfying thing
that I do then a lot of the a lot of the
challenges
they make sense I guess is the thing
they make sense to you
um and and and I should say I I want to
Echo what you say though about the way
that entrepreneurs maybe think that what
they're doing is a is a a some kind of
unique path that um others who don't
take it are are lesser for
um I think that we actually need to
separate
the the the mentality of
Entrepreneurship from like the having
started a business because if people and
people can think like an entrepreneur
people can
have a goal and set out to reach it they
can try to build things for themselves
you don't have to have started a
business to do that it's one way to do
it but I'm not going to go tell you that
that's the only way in which you can
create fulfillment or the only way in
which you can create value I think the
most important thing is that we are just
aware of the value that we can provide
and we're pushing ourselves to
constantly evolve and understand that
newness creates opportunity that when
there's new out there when things change
that means that people need new things
and you can step up in whatever role you
occupy and you can provide that thing
that other people need and people will
love you for it that to me is core to
what entrepreneurship really is whether
you start a company or not I agree with
that
um
before we get out of here yeah I want to
make sure I allow you the time to like
talk about anything in the book that you
think would bring this heavily
entrepreneurial based audience some
value what what uh what have we not
talked about serendipitously in this
conversation so far that might be worth
mentioning and or even it's not in the
book The General concept of you know
entrepreneurship yeah
I
I I I'm gonna tell you um like a kind of
quick crazy story
when the car first was brand new when
the car was brand new turn of the
century people didn't call it the car
they called it the Horseless Carriage
and that was if they were being generous
otherwise they called it the devil wagon
and that was because they hated this
thing people didn't understand this
thing and uh they threw rocks at it if a
car went down on the by the street
people would stand on the street corner
they'd say like get a horse they'd yell
at the car and uh now when we talk about
why the car became the dominant form of
transportation the story We Tell is
Henry Ford we say Henry Ford
he revolutionized manufacturing as a
result
he made cars more accessible and
affordable to people you know that
that's true but that's not the whole
story I learned this fascinating thing
from uh and I'm not just telling you a
history story I'm telling you a lesson
that we're going to all apply to
ourselves so I'll get there in a second
um the this woman who had studied the
history of automobile told me that the
big mistake that automobile
manufacturers made at the very beginning
was that they started talking about the
car as a replacement to the horse they
said get rid of Dobbin your horse right
right this car much better you know what
people hated that people found that
offensive because they loved their horse
their horse was a member of the family
for Generations their horse their their
families that had horses and now here's
somebody coming along and saying I have
a better way to do things you are an
idiot get rid of your old thing and it
turns out and here's the thing that I
think we all need to remember people
don't like new things you know what they
like they like better versions of old
things like better versions and and
they're and they're incredibly romantic
of yesterday yeah and Incredibly I mean
it's happening in nft land right now
like the amount of Happiness from so
many people that nft values are icy
reminds me literally to the exact same
feeling of March 2000 when internet
stocks crashed and all my 45 year old
friends which seemed like a thousand
when I was 22 24. they were like see you
know just open up another I mean God the
amount of times I heard just open
another liquor store stop playing around
with the computer you know you'll sell a
lot more wine if you open a second
liquor store and and it's just
incredibly fascinating how much people
fear new stuff but but check this out
because because yes they fear new stuff
but they love better versions of old
stuff they love you to improve the thing
that they want so you know what we need
to do yeah
go ahead yeah so the thing that we need
to do is we need to build a bridge of
familiarity whenever we introduce
something new to people or frankly
whenever we are faced with something new
ourselves we cannot start with here's
the the new thing and here's why it's
better we have to start with what are
you already familiar with what do you
already need in your life what is the
core thing that you are looking for
whether that's Comfort or growth or or
Insight or whatever it is and then build
from there for the cars what they did is
they stopped talking about cars as a
replacement to the horse and they
started talking about cars as a better
horse they started talking about cars in
terms of horses they named cars after
horses like Mustang and things we have
today started using words like
horsepower and they started to show
people how this thing was a better
version
what they already have and I think that
as entrepreneurs as innovators as people
who want to bring new into the world
what we cannot forget is that people may
not understand what we're up to they may
not understand the value that we're able
to bring and so what we have to do is
check ourselves and not focus so much on
how we have something that other people
can't live without but rather start with
them start with their problems start
with their needs and build I actually I
actually think a lot of Engineers
struggle with that because they're so
deep in the science I think one of the
roles I've been able to play in my
career is as a communicator has been
like no no we're going to break this
down to why and how not not yeah it's a
tremendous rant that you ended with that
I really hope
heck I was listening I was like you know
I might just tweak a hair the way I talk
about in my marketing meetings with
these CMOS and CEOs who are petrified
that television commercials are dead
right like like it's very hard even for
the most Ardent fans of TV ads
between social and now streaming
it's just getting very hard to believe
that spending millions of dollars on TV
commercials is a good use of money yeah
but you can see the fear
um and and it makes a ton of sense
um where can people pick up the book
Jace I mean I'm sure all the normal
places right yeah yeah all the normal
places bookstores Nationwide Amazon
wherever again it's called build for
tomorrow I'd love if you check it out
and what's the it's called build for
tomorrow but then there's also oh yeah
there's a whole there's a whole subject
do that do that yeah okay yeah so the
whole subtitle here I'm gonna hold the
book up whole subtitle is an action plan
for embracing change adapting fast and
future proofing your career because look
you can't you're not gonna be able to
say I know exactly what my career is
going to be like in 10 years but you can
make decisions right now that are going
to open the doors to the things that
you're going to be doing in 10 years and
that's the thing you need to be focusing
on everybody's listening I think you've
got a good sense of me at this point
even if you're new I'm not a very tough
read I'm a tricky read but not on this
one I get the author request 700
trillion times a day I've got a lot of
great relationships that are serious
that look like Jason an entrepreneur
Jason's at the show because I have a
funny feeling for a lot of you this is a
book that will help that makes me happy
um and and I still believe that
um reverse engineering how people learn
is the most important thing and some
people learn like me which is more audio
and visual and many of you most of you
learn quite well in long form books and
uh and obviously is there an audiobook
or do you read it there's an audiobook I
did it you know if you want it funny
thing uh because we're both high energy
guys I had in my ear the director of the
audiobook he kept yelling pillow talk at
me because I was talking too fast Pillow
Talk Pillow Talk you wouldn't want to
yell that pillow talk so I love listen
for The Pillow Talk mine was more I just
said I'm incapable of reading I actually
got better as a reader because of the
sheer fear that I would walk into Studio
of like how long not I I don't mind that
I can't read and I mispronounce words
and I can't read words that are basic I
struggled on the fact that I just wanted
to get through it so I could go to my
next meeting and so
um that's that's really funny Jason I'm
really happy for you you've worked
really hard I've watched from afar it
makes me happy for you it makes me happy
for the people who I think are going to
get a quality product that they consume
this book or listen to it and uh and I
continue to cheer for all the
entrepreneurs in the world and honestly
all the people that are self-aware to
realize they're not entrepreneurs but
can get something out of entrepreneurial
Frameworks and mindset which is what I
think you spent some real time on but I
think Maps incredibly well the parenting
personal relationships and many other
things so thank you for being on the
show okay thank you thank you for your
practical optimism Gary it it really it
changes lives and I appreciate the
relationship we have so great thanks for
having me
foreign
[Music]